dass das Programm im ZDF ohne feste
freie überhaupt nicht stattfinden würde
das ist ein großer Teil der Mitarbeiter
die diese Arbeit leisten und jetzt
erzähle ich kurz was einen Mitarbeiter
definiert also ein freier Mitarbeiter
ist die Jura im ZDF kein Mitarbeiter
wurde mir mehrfach mitgeteilt aber ich
hatte von Anfang an 18 Jahre lang meine
Lohnsteuerkarte da ich hatte einen ich
war im Dienstplan ich war weisungsbefugt
ich hatte einen festen Schreibtisch eine
E-Mail-Adresse einfach nur schlecht und
meinen Namen am Türschild solange ich
noch ein Einzelberater das heißt es sind
die juristischen Kategorien dafür dass
ich eine Mitarbeiterin war ich kann
immer nur vom ZDF sprechen wie hier
Mitarbeiter behandelt werden es gibt
Gerichtsverfahren das am Ende steht
immer eine saubere schweigeklausel die
natürlich nicht gebrochen werden darf
deswegen kommen diese Geschichten auch
nicht an die Öffentlichkeit ja also
warum ich ich habe ja hier eine
schweigeklausel gebrochen